[Aplausos]
[Música]
señoras y señores si esta noche vinieran
los personajes de men in black y nos
borrarán absolutamente toda la
información que tenemos en el cerebro
mañana por la mañana al despertar usted
por qué razón sería valioso
cuando yo me hice esa pregunta pasé
varios días en sincera angustia
existencial así que si en este momento
usted está sintiendo como alguna
incomodidad lo puedo entender
perfectamente y es muy posible que la
razón por la cual no somos capaces de
contestar porque es razón seríamos
valiosos se debe a que somos hijos de un
sistema educativo que en la mayoría de
los casos se ha dedicado a entender qué
es lo que se necesita que las masas
hagan para que produzcan más para que
produzcan mejor pero que en muy contadas
excepciones se ha preguntado cómo se
necesita que la gente piense es más como
le convendría a la gente aprender a
pensar en función de su felicidad
si la educación quisiera realmente ser
un vehículo para nuestra felicidad
debería a partir de supuestos distintos
se me ocurren un ejemplo por ahora
podrían enseñarnos que para poder ser
felices a largo plazo en la vida
necesitamos ser más inteligentes que
nuestro cerebro nuestro cerebro por
cierto se rige por dos comandos
fundamentalmente uno ahorrar energía y
dos sentirse feliz a partir del hecho de
sentirse creativo y esto se los digo
para que sepamos que nuestro cerebro
cuando está ahorrando energía no es que
sea un cerebro perezoso lo que pasa es
que el cerebro tiene que optimizar la la
energía de la que dispone entendamos
esto del 100 por ciento de energía que
hay en nuestro cuerpo nuestro cuerpo
tiene que administrar que manda para
hacer la digestión para que respiremos
para que comamos para que nos crezcan
las uñas el pelo para que podamos
procesar la información y el cerebro
representando únicamente el 2 por ciento
de nuestro peso corporal
curiosamente el solo cerebro él solito
se empaca entre el 20 y el 30 por ciento
de toda la energía de nuestro cuerpo
cuando yo supe eso por ejemplo sentí
ganas de comer algo dulce es posible que
alguno de ustedes en la audiencia esté
sintiendo eso ahora mismo se los digo es
porque tenemos que entender que nuestro
cerebro está diseñado para no pensar
porque necesita ahorrar el combustible y
cuando uno entiende eso entiende por
ejemplo por qué aquí entre no es porque
todo toca decirlo cuando vamos a seducir
seducimos básicamente con el mismo
libreto de siempre todas las veces
cuando vamos a las fiestas hacemos más
básicamente los mismos chistes y a la
mayoría de nuestros amigos les
resolvemos toda la vida con los mismos
tres consejos de siempre de nuevo es que
el cerebro tiene razones biológicas
objetivas para no querer pensar como
esto es así y de nuevo pensando en el
rol de la educación una cosa muy útil
que podrían hacer nuestros educadores es
enseñarnos desde pequeñitos con mandos
de felicidad es decir comandos de
priorización para que a la hora de tomar
decisiones la cosa nos quede más fácil
se me ocurre lo siguiente supongamos
digamos que en nuestro salón de clases
llenamos un letrero que dice lo
siguiente la felicidad es mi derecho
no mi obligación voy por la vida a mi
propio ritmo
si yo esto lo he oído desde que soy una
niña después cuando tenga 25 o en mi
caso 34 años y esté ante la disyuntiva
de si firmar un crédito hipotecario o no
para obligarme 20 años para pagar una
casa bajo la presión de que todos mis
amigos en las redes sociales están
viviendo una vida perfecta viven en una
casa propia si yo tuviera esto claro
desde que soy pequeñita posiblemente yo
recordaría el que la feliz y la
felicidad es mi derecho no es mi
obligación que yo voy a mi ritmo y sobre
todo que yo no tengo por qué dar el paso
más largo que la pierna
yo voy haciendo la vida como iniesta
mente la puedo hacer
ahora nos convocan esta mañana el tema
de la educación y en mi caso de la
felicidad hice igualmente que es
inevitable que en el auditorio haya
personas que hagan pero bueno la
felicidad pues sí es un asunto lindo
pero eso es la felicidad para después si
eso es así me gustaría proponerles que
nos pongamos en contexto entendamos lo
siguiente mientras nosotros estamos aquí
en el auditorio de la pontificia
universidad católica del ecuador estar
al mismo tiempo afuera los planetas
júpiter saturno ven todas esas cosas
otras galaxias otros universos el
espacio sideral nosotros venimos siendo
unas hormiguitas cósmicas y nuestra vida
nuestra vida está comparada con la línea
del tiempo del universo es una cosa muy
corta señoras señores díganme si lo más
bonito que podemos hacer con la
posibilidad que tenemos de estar aquí no
es tratar de vivir una vida feliz y
también en cuanto se nos facilite ayudar
a que las personas que nos rodean vivan
una vida igualmente feliz
el sistema educativo de nuevo si
quisiera participar de una manera más
activa podría por ejemplo enseñarnos a
ejercer nuestra libertad ojo el verbo
que es que escogí ejercer en lugar de
usar porque tenemos que entender
igualmente que nuestra vida se compone
básicamente de decisiones y que la
felicidad sin lugar a dudas es una
decisión
como igualmente 6 que en este momento
algunas de las personas pueden estar
pensando bueno si la felicidad es una
decisión pero digamos que yo ya me
decidí a ser feliz y yo qué hago si
mañana tengo que volver al mismo trabajo
infame de todos los días o tengo que ir
a la misma universidad dónde me siento
derrotado entonces cuál es la decisión
puesto que yo no estoy proponiendo que
dejemos todo botado y que nos vayamos a
la playa a vivir a una aldea de
pescadores no se los propongo entre
otras cosas porque si viviéramos de
vacaciones amigos necesitaríamos
vacaciones de las vacaciones es que el
trabajo está en el orden de la
naturaleza no eso lo que estoy
proponiendo lo que le estoy proponiendo
en cambio son tres cosas primero que
decidamos más es decir que dejemos de
hacer que la vida vaya decidiendo por
nosotros y nosotros resolviendo en el
día a día nada de eso segundo que
decidamos con nuestro propio cerebro y
no con el de alguien más
y tercero que decidamos mejor o en otras
palabras por favor usted que me están
oyendo en este momento decida como lo
haría alguien que todavía está vivo no
como un autómata que está condenado a ir
todos los días a la misma parte
seguirlo de sobrevivir decida cómo lo
haría alguien que todavía está vivo pero
les decías un momentico que habría sido
lindo que sería lindo para las futuras
generaciones que nos enseñaran comandos
de felicidad pues bueno les voy a
compartir mis 5 favoritos ahora para oír
esto es posible que ustedes sientan que
les empieza a bombear demasiada
información paréntesis si eso es así no
sólo en relación con mi conferencia que
tengo el honor de hacer la conferencia
inaugural sino sobre todo con todas las
conferencias que siguen no tratemos de
aprendernos las cosas que oímos porque
no hace falta nuestro cuerpo es
tremendamente inteligente y él sabe
metabolizar las buenas ideas haga de
cuenta cuando uno se come por ejemplo
una naranja fíjense que el cuerpo no
está diciendo cómo es que se llama la
vitamina a vitamina c litio la vitamina
c m sí pero no uno se come la naranja y
el cuerpo sabe qué hace con eso lo mismo
con el conocimiento entonces de ahora en
adelante cuando usted encuentre un
'speaker' con el cual resuene usted
entregue se dulcemente a esas ideas
entre otras cosas porque aquí estamos en
un lugar seguro
saliendo del paréntesis lo que les
quería contar en lo siguiente la primera
idea que me habría gustado mucho que me
enseñaran en el colegio es hermoso antes
que productivo por favor de ahora en
adelante cada vez que usted está en la
posibilidad de elegir entre una cosa y
otra y se trata de una circunstancia
saludable frente a la cual usted sienta
que está a punto de de estimular lo que
es delicado dentro de la existencia
humana prefiere de su diez mil y un
millón de veces antes que ganarse un
dinerito a corto oa mediano plazo
acuérdese hermoso antes que productivo
segundo
traicionarme a mí para no traicionar a
otro en todo caso es traicionar es más
es la peor traición esta es una frase de
mil donas watch que quise incluir en
esta conversación por lo siguiente sé
que sabía que tendría el honor de
dirigirme al auditorio compuesto
fundamentalmente por personas jóvenes
como nos falta mucha vida para adelante
la idea es que en la media lo posible
pues no traicionamos a nadie por
supuesto pero eso sí bajo ninguna
circunstancia sea usted quien se
traiciona a sí mismo de ahora en
adelante cuando nos falte tiempo que el
tiempo que pongamos no sea justamente el
de trabajar en nuestro entrenamiento
corporal espiritual intelectual no no se
vuelva a traicionar a usted mismo tercer
postulado o hasta que me encanta el
antónimo de pensar es creer otra vez el
antónimo de lo opuesto a pensar es creer
amigos tenemos que cuestionar todo lo
que creemos la sabiduría popular que
entre otras cosas de pronto están de
acuerdo conmigo no es nada distinto a un
conjunto de necesidades y locuras que
solamente le llena la cabeza de taras
escogemos un dicho por escoger
bueno lo que mal empieza mal acaba lo
sabemos desde siempre por estar pensando
así por estar creyendo eso cuando uno
está delante de un problema en lugar de
pensar cuál es la solución uno dice no
como lo que mal empieza mal acaba eso ya
que me voy por el despeñadero cuidao
cuando usted está creyendo eso
pregúntese y según quién y a
continuación decida
porque usted me está oyendo al otro lado
recuerde ninguno de nosotros eligió como
empezaba el cuento de su vida pero
siempre podemos elegir cómo acaba en
quinto lugar y en cuarto lugar
la felicidad es mi derecho no mi
obligación voy por la vida a mi ritmo
esto se lo dice se lo dije hace un
momento pero se lo repito ahora por una
razón por más teorías de felicidad que
alguien tenga recuerde que nadie sabe lo
que se siente vivir bajo su propio
pellejo nadie sabe lo que se siente
presentarse todos los días con su cuerpo
con su figura con su género tener sus
sueños sus ilusiones sus miedos entonces
por más que otra persona se vea versada
no permita que alguien le marque el
ritmo de su vida y en quinto lugar
pregúntese siempre que haría el amor
aquí y use esto como criterio de
decisión amigos si si si tuviéramos que
darle un nombre a esta energía de la que
está bueno porque somos energía no son
energía si no que tuviéramos que darle
un nombre a esta energía a la que
estamos hechos diríamos que es amor y
cuando uno toma conciencia de que uno es
amor la vida se le vuelve más linda
porque entonces uno comparte más porque
uno dice lo siento más fácilmente porque
uno hace esa llamada telefónica más
fácilmente estas cosas como estamos
viendo pues uno las puede aprender
también de grande lo que pasa es que
después de muchos golpes contra el
pavimento y muchas lágrimas así que si
le aprendiéramos
pequeñitos pues sería mejor ahora esto
bien podemos tomarle una fotografía
porque hay otras cosas que quiero
decirle que son las siguientes
acuérdense que les dije el cerebro tiene
dos comandos uno el de ahorrar energía 2
el de sentirse feliz por la vida de ser
creativo estos parecen comandos que se
contraponen pero no es así cuando usted
se siente creativo haga de cuenta cuando
usted se enamora cuando uno se enamora
se le ocurre en 10.000 ideas no le da
hambre no le da frío en nada
superman pues porque es porque su
cerebro se está cargando de energía
siendo creativo y esto se los digo es
porque la vida he podido encontrar la
vida tiende a premiar a las personas que
son más creativas con lo cual hay que
entender cómo funciona esto de la
creatividad en mi sentir este cuadro
representa perfectamente lo que les
quiero transmitir es uno de los más
influyentes en mi vida es la escuela de
atenas de rafael sanz yo lo propongo en
esta conversación porque si nos fijamos
primero aquí está el momento de la
creación del mundo que tratas como lo
digo de una manera poética porque están
los pensadores más importantes de la
antigüedad segundo porque si nos fijamos
aquí nadie está labrando la tierra
no no se detuvieron a pensar y es que
así es como nace las buenas ideas mi
papá que es una persona bueno mi papá es
mi superhéroe dentro de su oficina
abogado está este cuadro y como
corresponde al superhéroe prácticamente
todo lo que yo he dicho me lo enseñó él
y una de las cosas más lindas que me
hizo notar es que quienes nacimos en la
clase media caemos en el error de pensar
que todo el tiempo tenemos que estar
produciendo algo haciendo algo como si
eso nos hiciera más valiosos amigos las
buenas ideas se producen es en contextos
como este compartiendo buenas ideas y
entre otras cosas teniendo buenas
conversas a buenas conversaciones a
propósito aquí una cosita ojo a sus
amigos digamos a la clase de reuniones
que usted frecuenta si a usted todo toca
decir si a usted le pasa que está en una
reunión y usted es el más inteligente
sospeche no se sospeche
mire yo a mí me encanta buscarme
reuniones donde me siento como en medio
de un ping-pong entre intelectuales así
que van las ideas y yo no tengo nada que
decir a mí eso me pone la cabeza a mí y
me encantan tus ojos y con los amigos lo
que hacerle curaduría a los amigos bien
pero les decía esto es porque la
creatividad es todo la creatividad es
nada más y nada menos que a escala por
supuesto a escala la forma de hacer
nuestros propios milagros para que su
vida cambie usted no necesita que
alguien venga a rescatarlo usted lo que
necesitas aprender a pensar distinto y
resolverse a hacer eso que en las tripas
usted sabe que tiene que hacer porque
uno siempre sabe lo que tiene que hacer
cuando uno entiende esto va a entender
que la felicidad no es algo que uno
obtiene de las cosas la felicidad es
algo que uno pone a su vida con qué pues
con su actitud cuando uno empieza a ver
la vida así uno deja de ser como un
mendigo que está suplicando que alguien
le ponga un poquito de atención que
alguien le dé un episodio lindo nada de
eso ganamos independencia emocional es
que es más ahora que estamos aquí todos
hagamos un experimento piensen por favor
en la cosa más bonita la más emocionante
la más chévere que les haya pasado en el
transcurso de los últimos cinco años
búsqueda por favor
bien si yo le preguntará usted se
acuerda de lo feliz que se sentía en ese
momento sí y si yo les preguntara ahora
mismo usted se siente así muy feliz pues
en muchos casos no estamos normal aquí
oyendo el cuento a la señora se cuenta
las cosas externas nos dan la picos de
alegría pero esa no es nuestra felicidad
cuando uno entiende eso deja de verse
mendicante y si lo aprendemos desde la
escuela nos va a pasar que nos podría
pasar que nos ven nuestro diploma de
bachiller sí pero que al lado diga que
nos acreditan también como líderes
líderes que para terminar tienen muy
claras tres cositas primero que lo
normal es ser feliz amigos yo esto se lo
oí por primera vez al profesor salvatore
nátoli y cambió mi vida se les propongo
porque pronto puede cambiarle a ustedes
ojo a esto vamos a ver para demostrar
que lo normal es ser feliz usted cómo
hace para saber que tiene hambre
que lo normal es no tener hambre usted
como hace para saber que tiene frío lo
normal es estar bien y usted cómo hace
para saber que está estresado de mal
genio o que tiene un dolor porque lo
normal es todo tenerlo señoras y señores
si no viniéramos de un estado originario
de felicidad no tendríamos una felicidad
para extrañar cuando la perdemos con lo
cual lo normal si es ser feliz pero
ahora una cosa que es igualmente
importante ojo aquí en el colegio si nos
enseñaron muy bien que en español una
cosa es ser y otra cosa es estar una
cosa es ser feliz y otra cosa es estar
contento o aquí ser feliz es su
condición normal ser contento es algo
que estará en sí torio por eso no nos
podemos confundir la segunda idea que
entenderíamos como líderes es que no
necesitamos que nuestra vida sea
perfecta para que sea una vida que valga
la pena ser vivida atención
amigos si no hubiéramos encarnado en
esta experiencia material si fuéramos
por allá una energía en el colmo no de
que pues lindo pero no tendríamos como
sentir como es la lluvia en nuestra piel
que se siente enamorarse a qué sabe la
pizza paradójicamente cuanto más
evitamos los problemas es en realidad la
vida lo que estamos evitando amigos
nosotros vinimos aquí a que nos pasen
cosas está bien que nos pasen cosas es
más pongan el pecho que le pasen cosas
cuando mi mamá me dice mi hijita que no
le pase nada yo digo no no no no no que
me pasa que me pase yo vine a eso
vivimos a aprender cosas y por último
tomen esto en consideración poder
enfocar la atención es nuestro verdadero
superpoder usted es prácticamente
aquellas cosas a las que usted presta la
atención la mayor parte de su tiempo así
que recuerde cada vez que pueda elegir
enfóquese en hacerlo como una persona
que todavía está viva que todavía tiene
derecho a soñar segundo asegúrese de
estar usando su propia cabeza y no la de
alguien más y tercero por favor
tómese este en este asunto en serio
porque ahí donde está cada uno de
nosotros
está escribiendo su autobiografía muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]